i'm shelly hall i'm an assistant
professor of paleontology at yale
university and an assistant curator of
invertebrate paleontology at the lp body
museum
66 million years ago an asteroid nearly
as big as Manhattan as long slammed into
the Yucatan Peninsula and it hit so hard
it nearly touched the mantle and threw
dust and ash and aerosols into the sky
and blackened out the Sun the earth got
really cold and really dark and it
rained fire and brimstone from the sky
and in that moment and in the years that
followed most life on Earth went extinct
on land it's really hard to preserve
fossils because everything gets washed
away by the weather but in the ocean on
the other hand everything rains down to
the bottom of the ocean and at the
bottom of the ocean are tons of plankton
and they tell us stories about past mass
extinction events and past abrupt
climate change events and essentially
how the Earth's evolved over a really
long time periods
first way we tried and tackle
question was to figure out the ages of
the rocks but it turns out that what a
volcano does to kill off life is
actually release a lot of nasty gases
and the gases come out at a different
time than the rocks so my group went and
we looked for traces of the gases and
what that allowed us to do was say that
no it really was the impact so 66
million years ago right at the death of
the dinosaurs it was the impact that did
the teeth
by studying past mass extinctions we can
understand what happened and which
species went extinct and where and what
happened afterwards how did things
recover and the hope is that by studying
that we can better inform how we treat
our world today how we protect species
and and make plans for the future that's
bound to be different